hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who Christmas special video
hopefully you've had a chance to see it
definitely a lot of fun not quite what I
expected but it was really fun Nick
Frost totally killed it as Santa Claus
and everyone really wants to talk about
the ending as well as you know the one
big twist in the middle so we'll get to
that so I'll start with top five moments
and then I'll do Easter eggs and then my
review and a new round of the giveaway
starts right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video
real simple and I'll just do a Q&A
tomorrow we're all announce the winner
so tangerines and magic carrots let's
get going
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet starting with top
five moments number five Santa meets
Clara for the first time I guess we
should say dream Santa Claus meets car
for the first time she seemed surprised
to see him so if she saw Santa Claus in
her dreams as a child he looked
different I totally loved Nick Frost but
I haven't seen a lot of his non Cornetto
stuff so my mind mostly went to that
place whenever I was watching him kind
of stumble over his words trying to
pretend like he was not Santa Claus I'm
sure somewhere Edgar Wright and Simon
Pegg were laughing their butts off the
elves if you didn't recognize them Dan
Starkey obviously plays Strax just looks
a little weird without his Strax makeup
on
Nathan McMullen is actually from misfits
that's where most people probably
recognize him from I was glad later in
the episode that they did call back to
this moment
Clara meet him on the rooftop for the
first time number four Faye marsay
dances the dream crabs away for the
first time this is like our first intro
to the dream crabs and we don't really
get a lot of context but just the fact
that she starts dancing to the Christmas
music was just so hilarious it just
seems like the appropriate weirdness for
a Doctor Who Christmas special episode
it's like something that Matt Smith
would do just start dancing wildly if he
didn't recognize her I mean at least I
think of Faye Marseille is mostly being
from the White Queen but she has done
some other stuff too she was actually
one of my favorite characters in the
Christmas special just in general like
the guest stars it really felt like they
were teasing her as a potential new
companion so I will totally add her to
my list of people I'd like to see become
companions in series 9 Faye marsay fir
to the next Doctor Who companion she
just lands right in that like perfect
territory where she's super quick she
has a super quick wit she's funny and it
looks like she's a little starved for
adventure given that she's a Game of
Thrones fan don't you just wonder why
she didn't conjure like Tyrion or Jaime
or someone else from Westeros to saber I
mean this is the Doctor Who special so I
didn't expect any Game of Thrones jokes
so I was actually really happy when I
saw that on her paper at the end if you
really want to put your tinfoil Theory
hat on her saying I'm scared in the
doctor replying good that means you're
not an idiot is the best sign that he
thinks someone has companion potential
like if the doctor is subtly evaluating
people like everyone he meets sizing
them up I think that would be a big plus
if he were in the market for a new
companion especially at the end when she
wants to exchange numbers with everyone
it just reminded me of the girl in the
shop and I do believe I think her
character actually said she did work in
a shop I can't remember what type of
shop it was though just so many
coincidences but if we're talking like
in Sherlock terms there's no such thing
as coincidences the universe is rarely
so lazy
number three Michael Troughton really
likes Ridley Scott for those that don't
know Michael Troughton is the younger
son of the second doctor he actually has
an older brother they've both done a lot
of Doctor Who stuff
previously Michael has been in a big
finished story a second doctor big
finished story called the Lords of the
red planet it's really his older brother
David that's been in a lot of Doctor Who
he was in midnight during series 4 he
was in a lot of classic episodes as a
child with his father when Patrick
Troughton was still playing the second
doctor on TV he's played villains and a
couple Big Finish stories and he was one
of the Dalek operators during the five
ish doctors reboot during the 50th
anniversary last year and in real life I
think they've also starred with some of
the other doctors former doctors that is
in outside productions stuff that isn't
Doctor Who just to explain the alien
joke that he made though to the doctor
which i think is totally hilarious the
doctor has never heard of Ridley Scott
apparently he's not a fan although I do
think that he has seen films like he
understands what movies are but they
called out alien literally I mean cuz of
the facehuggers but I also saw dream
warriors from Nightmare on Elm Street
whenever he got sucked into the TV then
you have John Carpenter's the thing with
aliens being dug out of the ice and then
you have the inception angle with the
dreams within dreams especially with
that ending moment - with the tangerine
that's like the little top spinning at
the end of Inception one of my favorite
things about Doctor Who is that it's not
afraid to get super metal like this and
do these kinds of jokes usually what
they do whenever they're conceiving
episodes is like they have their
storyline and then after the fact like
after the story is done they're like hey
let
kind of make this look like dream
warriors or poltergeist where someone
gets sucked into the TV they don't
intentionally write it to be like some
other movie either those references were
added after the fact I like the idea
that Moffat wrote the special and then
after the fact was like you know this
kind of looks like John Carpenter's The
Thing
or maybe the Alien movie number two
Danny pink cameo they said ahead of time
that they'd be referencing the events of
the finale so Danny pink was at least
going to be mentioned I was a little
surprised to see him but the minute
Clara went into the dream I felt like we
all probably knew yet we're probably
gonna see Danny pink here I like that
they paid off the blackboards two
blackboards were such a big deal during
series 8 they didn't totally explain it
I mean it's just as far as we know the
doctor likes to write things down in the
episode he's trying to tell fara
something through her subconscious but
maybe during series 8 when he wrote on
what those blackboards and wasn't sure
who wrote those things down he was
trying to tell himself something
subconsciously I think that mostly dove
tailed with the master coming back like
he was trying to tell himself about that
but it's possible that it could have
been something else
Buffett's been honest about the fact
that series 8 as well as Capaldi's run
in general isn't quite as planned out as
Matt Smith's run like whenever Matt
Smith started his run he had a pretty
good idea of where trenzalore was going
he said that now though he only has a
few ideas about the twist he doesn't
have it completely worked out just cuz I
think they're not really sure when cap
Ali's gonna leave he has signed out
through series 10 but it remains to be
seen whether or not he's gonna make it
as long as Matt Smith or David Tennant
Samuel Anderson was totally great they
played it a little fast and loose with
the logic really it's qara talking to
herself even though the doctors in there
also talking to her like the way they
share dreams is a little fuzzy fuzzy on
the logic there's two ways to think
about it the dream crabs are like the
holodeck like they set the stage and
your mind fills in the gaps like it
creates everything or you could look at
some of the characters as being created
by the dream crabs I think it's the
first one I think that the dream crabs
just create the holodeck and you are
completely responsible for filling it
out with the scenario that's why they
can conjure Santa to defend themselves
as like a defense mechanism Danny pink
is also kinda in that Santa vein and he
was even wearing a Santa costume and the
doctor even called her out on it you
know that this is fake so I think that
she conjured Danny pink as a way to see
him again and as a defense mechanism
just for those that are
yes I do think that Danny pink is still
dead there isn't some crazy twist this
is gonna be some inception middle finger
from Offutt saying that it was all a
dream
the tangerine at the end did kind of
make you wonder that but no I don't
think it's gonna be that crazy I think
he is still dead Danny pink still dead
that was what the whole last Christmas
theme was about their very last
Christmas or the bonus Christmas like
Danny peen called it and my number one
moment
Doctor Who inception you can look at the
dreams within dreams twist a couple
different ways one it's a little bit of
a middle finger saying that oh you know
none of this was real you spent all this
time invested in this storyline haha I
don't get too upset by stuff like that I
mean I think I think it's okay I'd be
more pissed off if they did that in the
finale where they were like this whole
season has been a dream that would be
bullcrap the whole idea of the shared
dream or shared nightmare as the doctor
eventually called it whatever it turned
into poltergeist and people started
getting sucked into the TV it goes all
the way back to listen you know with
little boy Danny pink and the doctor has
that crazy idea you know what if we all
have the same nightmare everyone in the
universe all at some point in their
lives like the idea of a shared dream
and I know there are a lot of questions
about Santa maybe baby not being a Time
Lord I don't think that he is but the
fact that there was a tangerine at the
end and I do think that they were awake
although it was kind of meant to be the
big question mark you know are they
dreaming are they not dreaming I think
he's an alien like the doctor who has
some metaphysical properties although I
do like the idea of the rudolph clicker
like the beeper like he closes in like a
car door it does make you wonder if he
has Time Lord technology and I know a
lot of people weren't huge fans of it
but the whole real not real you know is
the doctor fictitious is he a real
person goes back to a robot of Sherwood
with Robin Hood is Robin Hood real is he
not real do the doctors adventures have
to be real to influence people or is the
effect that they have on people the only
thing that matters really to me that
feels like the big hand wave you know
don't worry too much about this all that
matters is is that these Doctor Who
stories make you feel something
I've seen that in a lot of cartoons this
year don't overanalyze things
don't let the truth get in the way of a
good story so every once in a while I do
just find myself getting swept up in
stories and having fun just one more big
Moffat fairy tale let me know that what
was your favorite moment from the
episode and here's my big question for
you guys would you guys want to see Faye
marsay she played show no would you want
to see her become the next companion
just an update on
series 9 so yes Cara as seen in the
episode when they announced that she's
coming back for series 9 supposedly
she'll be leaving after the first couple
of episodes maybe as late as halfway
through the series as far as we know
that's the plan right now that could
always change you could always change
your mind it's down for the entire
series or leaves sooner they're still
planning that out they've only planned
the first couple of episodes even though
Moffat has an idea for what he wants the
twist to be in the finale he was talking
about it in the latest issue of Doctor
Who Magazine he just said I have an idea
for what the big twist is gonna be at
the end of series 9 but it's not as
planned out as trans lore was whenever
Matt Smith started in the 11th hour
so here are just a couple of the Easter
eggs that I haven't already mentioned
one of my favorite ones is when they're
reading the first word out of the books
Clara has them all open it to page 12
the words are very very very good
it's like Capaldi and Moffat are just
patting themselves on the back they're
just a little bit I don't think that
they were trying to make a direct
reference to it but I do think that when
Capaldi went on whatever the doctor was
explaining the brain freeze it was a
little there will be blood like I take
your milkshake your brain milkshake and
drink it up that's all I could think
about I take your brain milkshake Nick
Frost had a lot of good jabs at the
doctor mostly calling him out as
potentially fictitious too but the
dreamy wee me is a nice spin on timey
wimey
I'm really hoping it doesn't catch on
though I'm not a big fan of dreamy wee
me as we learned Series 9 episode 1
gonna be called The Magician's
apprentice
there was actually a line that Shona had
whenever she was scolding the doctor
that's not very nice for someone who
looks like a magician they really are
lenient to the magician joke I totally
appreciate that and the really big one
was it looked like the doctor whatever
he woke up from his dream crap was
inside the volcano from the finale which
implies he could have gone back there he
could have been somewhere else like it
could have not been the volcano it just
looks like the same set that actually
had me worried I was like oh man please
don't let the finale be a dream so if
you saw any other Easter eggs that I
didn't mention just write them below in
the comments generally you know it was a
lot of fun overall I gave the episode a
solid a it was great as a Christmas
episode very self-contained while still
having a lot of references to some of
the events during the regular series I
always give bonus points to stories when
you don't you do I have to completely
understand everything because I always
try to get new people into Doctor Who
and it's really hard to do that when the
story depends on other episodes it's
like you could have watched this without
understanding who Danny pink is and you
just known that he was someone who had
passed away who was very precious to
Clara Capaldi felt very on character
like I mean he was just a still the same
standoffish doctor who are you people
sorry I erased you very mind policy very
sherlocky I know a lot of people have
opinions about Clara I did feel like
Jenna Coleman did a good job in this
episode I'm interested to see what they
do with her character like if they
decide to pursue the doctor Clara Moore
or dr. Oswald however you want to think
about her I'd like to see them take a
break from that so I was kind of glad
when she didn't go off doctor in this
episode it did seem like she was
unusually scared of the dream crabs
I thought the screaming was a little
much I mean if she could take on the
Cybermen if she could lie to their face
to save herself
why was she so scared of the dream crabs
she went from like cold-blooded killer
in the span of a couple months or
however long it's been since the events
the finale and the timeline to like
scared girl again they did imply that
she was gonna start moving on so it
seems like she's gonna be a little more
positive in future episodes which i
think is great because Clara being
depressed there's no fun there's no room
for being depressed on the TARDIS when
you have all of time and space you're
not allowed to be depressed all the
guest actors were great Michael trodden
it was so much fun seeing him Faye
marsay was probably my favorite though
just because I feel like she has so much
companion potential and for those that
are asking
I feel like Moffat does know who the
next companion is gonna be if they're
gonna shoot the first episode really
soon he probably has at least a list of
three or four people that they wintered
it down to if they haven't picked
someone they're really close to picking
someone they announced Samuel Anderson's
casting pretty early in the process
whenever they were filming series 8
so it's possible we could find out by
like February or March who the new
campaign is gonna be and I really am
hoping that we see the new companion in
the premiere at least in a cameo so just
a couple quick updates on what's
happening this week's things are slowly
getting back to normal they'll be
shooting the Sherlock Christmas special
before the first episode of series 9 so
I will be doing some videos for Sherlock
in the next couple days I'm also working
on a Q&A for tomorrow so be sure to
leave all your questions and if you guys
want me to do a live Q&A on my twitch
channel let me know I'll actually put a
link to my twitch channel in the
description my next Doctor Who bonus
video is probably going to be just
ranking all my favourite Christmas
specials just now that we have a new one
just to kind of put them all in context
again so if you do have a big favorite
Christmas special let me know in the
comments too right now if you're on your
mobile phone or on a tablet you can
actually click here for new mobile links
yay mobile links is the same as the
links
here so click here for that Q&A that
I'll be posting tomorrow and click here
for all my other Doctor Who bonus videos
thank you so much for watching
so everybody happy holidays enjoy some
time enjoy your vacation hopefully you
get one let's all high-five I'll see you
tonight
you